ambassador
giving lectures on democracy topics we
enjoyed and learned a great deal he is
here today to give the first of four
lectures in the Henry Stimson lecture
series which is named for a Yale
graduate in the class of 1988 who became
a Secretary of War under William Howard
Taft later Secretary of State under her
Hoover and then again 1940 Secretary of
War under Franklin Roosevelt and for
some time now the center has been
sponsoring students and lectures and
it's a pleasure for us to do this this
year and to have an ambassador named
mark here he entered the Foreign Service
after studying Russian and
after teaching the percussion at
Dartmouth College for two or three years
and had a long career in the Foreign
Service and served on several occasions
in Moscow beginning in the early 60s
when he was a I believe a council and
vice council and the third secretary and
in fact during the Cuban Missile Crisis
of 1962 he was one of the people
translating the telegrams that were
going back and forth between JFK and
Nikita Khrushchev he spent some time in
Africa in various embassies in Africa
and then returned to Washington and was
the director for Soviet affairs and the
State Department spent time as the for
four years
in the 1970s as a counselor and the
deputy chief of mission cm in Moscow in
1981 he became the chargee that fair and
ambassador in Moscow and was also
appointed as the ambassador to
Czechoslovakia two years later he was
asked by President Reagan who to return
to Washington become a special assistant
for the President and Senior Director
for European and Russian affairs in the
National Security Council and he held
that position in three years then during
that time was intimately involved in the
negotiations and the summits including
Reagan and Gorbachev and the
negotiations over in 1997 he was
appointed ambassador to the Soviet Union
and spent four years in Moscow as
ambassador leaving shortly before the
demise of the Soviet Union as a
territory and refused the money which
were immense declarations
since his retirement ambassador Matlock
has taught at several colleges in fact
he just came today from having talked
yesterday at Hamilton College he's
written extensively about American
foreign policy about the Soviet Union
and about post-soviet Russia from 1991
to 1996 he was the Katharine and Shelby
column Davis professor in the practice
of international diplomacy at Columbia
University and for five years after that
he was the George Kennan professor at
the Institute for Advanced Study at
Princeton and during that period he
wrote of two very important books one in
the Magisterial autopsy on an empire and
account
his years as an ambassador in the Soviet
Union 87 to 91 and more recently he
wrote a book entitled Reagan and
Gorbachev how the Cold War ended which
is the best account I've seen of the
negotiations pertaining to nuclear
weapons during the Reagan presidency and
he's still writing books in fact he has
a book that will be coming out shortly
and these lectures will be a separate
book that will be published by Yale
University Press next year so it's a
it's a pleasure to welcome to New Haven
to Yale and to the center Ambassador
John Matlock today he will be speaking
about this understanding Russia
east-west sweet generous tomorrow at the
same time at 4:00 he'll be speaking
about the 90s in the 90s in Russia
democracy or disarray and then on
Wednesday February 10th to be speaking
about Vladimir Putin's Russia and he'll
include the lectures on February 11th
speaking on living with Russia prospects
for the future so it's a real pleasure
to welcome thank you very much professor
Cameron and I must say that it is a very
great honor to come here and
particularly to deliver a lecture
lectures in a series dedicated to Henry
Stimson I think was one of the great
statesmen of the first half of the 20th
century and he was course aside from all
of his other achievements he was
Secretary of War during the Second World
War and immediately after knowing
these four lectures are talks I think of
them myself a little less formally than
that about America and Russia I have
selected a number of most of them are
well-known quotations over move the last
nearly 200 years that have been made
about Russia or about us-russian
relations I hope everybody had a chance
to get a copy on the way in because I
will be referring to them but I would
call your attention to the one from
Henry Stimson a comment he made to
President Truman in 1945 just a few
months as the war in Europe was ending
and it was that we must find a way of
persuading Russia to play ball he was
thinking about the post-world War two
world and how it was going to work out
if Russia didn't cooperate well the
Soviet Union and as I will be mentioning
later I think we do have to make a
distinction the Soviet Union at that
time was ruled by a man named Joseph
Stalin and Stalin for many reasons it
had nothing to do with Russian national
interest is such was totally unwilling
to play ball or to cooperate with the
West but that theme the fact that we are
not going to be able to put together you
might say a peaceful and constructive
world without cooperation with Russia
that the idea behind Stimson's comment
to Truman I think is still true and I
would say that quotation is one I will
be discussing in greater detail in the
fourth of these talks
as of today as I look back and being
reminded during professor Cameron's
introduction of some of my own
experiences I would have to say that I
am definitely not a prophet and though
in the last lecture I will try to talk a
little bit about what the contours of
the future might be I'm not gonna try to
predict I was often asked particularly
during my last tour in Moscow as the
Soviet Union was democratizing and
beginning to come apart I was often
asked by Soviet citizens what do you
think is going to happen you know well
this happened or that happen and I
haven't stock answer I would say look I
don't really know what's going to happen
now when it happens I'll be very happy
to explain why it was inevitable because
gonna need to look back you sort of
assumed that well this was the only way
things could have gone but when you look
forward you have to bear in mind that
there are a few such certainties and
that was certainly my case when I was
asked by President Reagan to go to
Moscow as ambassador I knew it was going
to be a tough time I hoped it would be a
time of change and where we could
improve the relationship but you know
and I hope that I could retire and have
a an active life even after that but it
never occurred to me that when I retired
the country to which I was accredited
would not be a country anymore and it
certainly didn't occur to me that they
were going to have to replace me with 15
ambassadors but that to happened so my
view of the future is one where it's
better to wait until it's past and then
your things can be clearer and in these
lectures I will be trying to look
things that happened in the past that
have a relevance to us today and which
we tend need to have in mind because
right now Russia is getting a very bad
press and indeed relations between the
United States and Russia or one would
think particularly reading by the
various reports as bad I would say worse
than they have been at any time since
the Soviet Union broke up
we've even began to hear that we may be
entering a new Cold War in fact Edward
Lukas The Economist correspondent and
Eastern Europe has published a book of
that title the new cold war Putin's
Russia and the threat to the West even
after that book was published we had the
shocks of the Russian invasion of
Georgia last August and cries that
obviously Russia seems to be intent upon
reassembling the Soviet Union using
imperialist methods and even more
recently we had a couple of weeks when
guest supplies that were passing from
and through Russia through Ukraine to
Europe the rest of Europe were shut down
was Russia playing politics playing
power politics with the gas supply many
people seem to think so others would say
hey this is a this is a squabble between
Russia and Ukraine primarily and one
which neither of them have played it
very well and I could go on and on of
course about some of these negative
things and in my third lecture I will go
on to in in greater detail but today I
want to look back and think in a rather
broader terms of the way we think about
Russia
there certainly are genuine problems
today in US relations with Russia and
some recent trends within Russia raise
genuine concern regarding their effect
on Russia's future no question about
that that Putin's Russia has grown more
authoritarian has shown less respect for
human rights than even Gorbachev did in
his final year there are a number of
negative trends nevertheless I feel that
much of the talk about Russia's threat
to the rest of the world has ignored the
context in which these developments have
occurred the context in which and the
historical background that happened
before these changes occurred within
Russia and in Russia sponsors in
particular there seems to be a
disconnect between those who comment on
what has happened internally in Russian
recently and the comment on how the
United States and Western European
countries treated Russia the sort of
precedence they set in the 90s and also
going in to the early 21st century now
they these quotations again that I have
here all of them except perhaps the one
that I cited with Henry Stimson are very
well known very common you have the de
Tocqueville prediction at the end of his
first his first volume on democracy in
America that Russia and America North
America the anglo-americans he as he put
it would between them coming from
different directions
each whole the fate of half the world in
their hands and wasn't that in fact the
idea people had when they spoke with the
bipolar world and when they spoke of the
east/west split during the Cold War I'll
be coming on that later because I I
think that although this idea was very
widespread it had serious faults and
then we had the famous quotation often
repeated quotation from Winston
Churchill
I cannot forecast to you the action of
Russia it is a riddle wrapped in a
mystery inside an enigma
now Churchill said that just a few days
after he learned about the nazi-soviet
pact suddenly after months indeed years
of negotiation with Stalin the Soviet
Union to form a united front against
Germany suddenly Stalin signs a treaty
with Hitler but was it Russia that
Churchill didn't understand or was it
stolen they did not understand that for
Stalin an agreement with Churchill and
the French is exactly the same as an
agreement with Hitler they're all class
enemies was divided and rule and you
would make temporary alliances as one or
the other but you would make the
alliance with the one that would give
you the most at least temporarily and
Hitler was willing to give Stalin a big
hunk of
Central Europe Britain was not willing
to sacrifice polish independence to the
Alliance again what is mysterious about
this but I would stress this was
Stalinism this was Stalin this was the
communist idea it was not necessarily
Russia in a national sense then the one
can ask and I'll have more to say about
this later well how did the Russians
view these things and typically if we go
back to the 19th century Russian opinion
tended to be split between the slava
files and what they call the
westernizers the westernizers feeling
that Russia's future was to go along the
lines they saw operating in Western
Europe which was increasingly toward I
would say more democracy rule of law
less autocracy whereas the Slava files
rejected that saying that the Russian
soul and the Russian Church the Russian
body politic was simply not subject to
these sort of rational measures that the
westernizers and the people in Western
Europe and they observed wanted to apply
and we have the very famous poem by a
furor to chef which ends with the line
varasi motion rhetoric of the eighties
in Russia one can only believe before
that he says that you there is no common
measure you can't measure Russia or
judge Russia by what he would have
called Western standards clearly this is
also associated with a theme and I'll
talk about this later anyway
we'll be returning to these quotations
some of which I agree with some of which
I don't but all of them give us a chance
to think about how the rest of the world
has thought about Russia you know I
think one of the most distorting
approaches has been the way we tend or
many people tend first of all to put
these questions and they sometimes in an
east-west the East is this the West is
this or Europe Asia or you know the
Occidental the Oriental Russia always
being you know on that oriental side
well obviously geographically Russia
lies to the east of the rest of Europe
but except in that sense these
dichotomies and they are usually in my
opinion quite over drawn another one
would be autocracy on the one hand
democracy on the other and the problem I
have several problems with this sort of
analysis that that has a conflicting
dichotomy first of all it supports an
assumption that these are opposites and
are inevitably in conflict and that
means that you tend to be in beatify one
and demonize the other and ignore a lot
of the detail the relevant detail in
between this attitude in general and not
just toward Russia but sort of dividing
the world between the good guys and the
bad guys
William fothe the columnist you often
see in the Herald Tribune has called the
infantile political manic ISM and I
think I think that really states it
pretty well and as I said
it applies not only to Russia but
particularly to Russia after all when we
hear well you know Ukraine really wants
to be in NATO because they want to be
part of the West
well the Ukrainian president does want
membership in NATO but why put it quite
in those terms I'll go into greater
detail in that but on these special
issues but my point here is that often
it sets up a contrast much more stark
than reality
the second problem I have with this sort
of either/or east/west autocracy or
democracy sort of thing is that it
really takes the issues that it applies
to out of historical context you get
into almost the infernal question is
Russia Europe or not and I'd like to
discuss that a little more because
there's so many approaches that one sees
that treats Russia as and this is true
in Russia as well as something sort of
different from the rest of Europe and
yet whether however you look at Russia
particularly since the from the 18th
century on they've been an intimate part
of Europe both European politics
European culture and this has gone both
ways I mean how can you know how can one
study the modern novel without studying
Tolstoy or Dostoyevsky
how can one think of modern drama
without knowing something about Chekhov
and and so on how about the dance ballet
the theater
Stanislavski technique you know you can
if this isn't part of European culture
is now so in a certain sense the idea
that Russia has been separate from
Europe and not really part of it
now of course Russia like any other
country has its unique aspects and of
course it also has Asian territories
territories that run east of the Urals
but basically its culture has been had
has been formed historically from the
beginnings of the Russian state in
Europe after all the first Russian state
was created by Vikings who came from
Scandinavia and went down the river
system and these were the first the
first Russian law is very similar to the
early anglo-saxon and the lik celica of
the Germanic peoples so you know back to
early medieval times essentially Russian
culture was part of Europe and I think
it has been since of course you did have
periods during the Mongol conquest for
example when Russia was under the sway
of the Mongols they were never totally
occupied and yet we never questioned
that Spain is a European country and
Spain sent much longer under the the
Moorish occupation and I think it's in
actually its culture has probably been
more influenced by Islam than done
Russian has so each of these things I
think it simply distorts the history if
you push it too far and then finally on
this dichotomy when we look at a current
issue we often simply ignore the
environment including the historical
precedence in which the negative changes
occurred you know how many of us when we
heard that Russia had invaded Georgia in
the enclaves South Ossetia last August
how many were told that the struggle
there began before Georgia was totally
independent when the Georgians attacked
the South descendants and tried to do
and tried to and did withdraw the
autonomy that they had had in the Soviet
Union and tried to force upon them you
might say - they tried to do to the
south of sentence and later the people
in Abkhazia what they accused the
Russians of doing to them that is to
dominate them and in effect to treat
them is without any rights for their own
ethnic existence I think finally her AAB
english professor at UCLA wrote an
article in The New York Review of Books
because he was in Georgia in 1990 and 91
when this was going on but most of the
news reporters you would have thought
well this was simply a matter of Russia
suddenly marches into Georgia you sort
of lose and I would say in this case
none of the players in that particular
drama comes out with clean hands I'm not
trying to excuse Russia but I'm simply
saying that when we are given a snapshot
of what happens without the background
of all the factors that go behind it and
then we make one side have all of the
right and the other side all of the
wrong we tend to make some serious
mistakes so I think that another
question that we need to clear up in our
minds and it's one that I think simply
because of our use of language tends to
get confused at times and that is what
is Russia
what are we referring to when we say no
Russia now when Henry Stimson told
Truman you know we've got to make we've
got to persuade Russia to play ball
he was talking about Soviet Union now
the Soviet Union is not the same as the
Russia we talked about today the Russian
Federation the Soviet Union was a
communist empire it was run within the
Russian Federation largely by ethnic
Russians but not entirely after old
Stalin was not even an ethnic Russian
they I would say the most destructive of
their dictators he was a Georgian and in
the other republics you increasingly
after World War two had the Republic's
run by people of that nationality and
that's why many Russian nationalists
back in the late Soviet period we're
trying to bring down the Soviet Union
because they said you know these
communists are treating Russia like a
colony that and that the communist state
and indeed one of the goals of the
Soviet Union was to create a new Soviet
man a person without a nationality but
with the characteristics of simply a
good citizen of a multinational state so
when we talk about what Russia does or
what Russian governments do which is
more appropriate we really have to bear
in mind which government we're talking
about and in the last hundred years
Russia has existed in at least four
distinct political forms you had Czar
ISM up until 1917 and there the you know
the basic by words where that rule was
autocracy orthodoxy and then a word in
Russian that is sometimes translated
nationalism but now rudeness is not what
we normally mean
say nationalism it really has to do the
spirit of the people so you had this are
the church and essentially the peasantry
because in our ordinance referred mainly
to that for a very brief period you had
the embryo parliamentary democracy
during the provisional government in
1917 the government that was destroyed
by the impact of World War one and the
Bolshevik Revolution and then we had the
Communist Empire which I think it was
although the the Soviet leaders
particularly from World War two on began
to assume many of the attitudes of the
earlier Czarist the period particularly
as regards foreign policy nevertheless
it was essentially a communist Empire
and one that was run by the Communist
Party the way a criminal organization
controls a front government if you get
an organized crime in a city or maybe
part of a city they can bribe the police
they probably own the mayor by their
electoral shenanigans and sort of
conduct their business through that the
Communist Party the Soviet Union treated
the Soviet state as a front organization
they had what they would call the famous
telephone law where judges or plant
managers or whatever would follow the
orders they received from from the party
secretary or the party official that was
assigned to supervise that particular
organization then finally we have the
Russian Federation of today
Sarris Russia the Soviet Union were both
very large empires the Russian
Federation has less than half the people
that the Soviet Union did when it
collapsed though it still occupies vast
stretches of territory and yet it also
has a population and I'll be mentioning
this later the impact which is declining
it is now down to I think about 145
million Soviet Union had around 300
million when when it broke up and close
to half went to the Russian Federation
but that population has been declining
ever since you have what is now a formal
democracy but one which which is has
much more autocratic practices then you
would find in in in a liberal democracy
on the other hand you have a government
that at least until the last few months
was running with about seventy percent
popularity so you have to start
wondering well how do you define
democracy is it a government that most
people are satisfied with or is it one
that people control and in this case the
people clearly don't control the
government on the other hand at least
until the this the low oil prices and
the financial meltdown has affected
Russia and it is affecting them severely
President Putin was extremely popular
and so is his successor Madhvi Jeff well
I've talked before a bit about is Russia
Europe or is it something else
and the problem there is that often
whether or not one says there's a lot of
that Russia has been part of the
European state system Russian culture is
part of Europe and all of that normally
when one uses the term today you equate
Europe with democracy and rule of law
market economics and and when you find
some of those things missing you get
again the application of this dichotomy
that Russia is somehow East and
different from the good west in Europe
there's no question in my mind looking
at it historically that many of the
characteristics that we find in Western
Europe today spread gradually west to
east over the centuries things like
representative government the abolition
of serfdom even before that and so on
you have and Martin Melia the late
historian at Berkeley who wrote about
this a lot coined the firm the term or
maybe he borrowed it I learned it from
him the cultural gradient where he
pointed out that many things and one of
the things he looked at was the
liberation of serfs serfdom would move
west to east
within each sort of band of liberation
forty to fifty years apart and he points
out that the last laws limiting serfs in
Prussia occurred around 1811 and of
course the serfs were freed in Russia
about 50 years later in 1861 and
ants gildner the sociologists made much
the same point when he talked about the
movement of democracy as it moved from
Western Europe into Central Europe and
the idea being that it is likely to move
into Russia that way frankly we still
don't know because one of the things
that I think we have to understand is
that again a lot of things can happen
that change these tendencies and and
when we begin to think about the sort of
things that happened in Russia after the
Soviet Union collapsed and that's my
subject tomorrow you can begin to see
that it's not a straightforward process
the development of democracy the
development of representative government
because despite the fact we often hear
everybody wants freedom you know I think
that's true if people have enough to eat
and feel reasonably secure but suppose
you're starving and suppose you live in
a crime-ridden neighborhood do you think
about freedom first or do you think
about survival and one of the problems I
have with the sort of indices that we
are kept by Freedom House which are very
useful in some respects is that they
don't tell you anything about the
economics about how people are living
just how much freedom they have and so
to put it on that without looking at
whether a given government whether
democratic or not is meeting the needs
as perceived by that society of social
support and economic support and
Economic Opportunity
and providing security unless you you
take account to that I think you're able
to get rather distorted views another
problem that I wanted to point out and
our perception of these things comes
from my thoughts about Samuel
Huntington's clash of civilizations I
don't know whether you've had a chance
to read that it was in the 90s it was
sort of obligatory reading for anyone
who was thinking about international
relations and professor Huntington who
died a few months ago and I think we
feel his loss his intellectual loss very
severely he taught us a lot about the
impact of different cultures can have on
the behavior but when he took that and
began to theorize to group it together
and theorize I think he led us a little
too far into the abstract among other
things he spoke of cultures as something
almost like nation-states are well
organized with finite boundaries and
that there were and he predicted that in
the future most of the conflict in the
world would be on these boundaries of
civilizations he defined civilization
very much the way Arnold Toynbee
the historian did and that means that he
put Russia in a different civilization
from Western Europe because Toynbee I
think rather illogically split Western
civilization off the Roman the
greco-roman civilization
because of Christianity but then when
there was the split in the churches
between Rome and Constantinople he said
okay so you've got an orthodox
civilization and you have a Western
Christian civilization but then he
didn't split Western civilization when
Protestantism came along he didn't split
Muslim civilization between Shia and
Sunni in other words some things caused
him to split other things didn't so he
has the Russia and a different
civilization from Western Europe because
of Russian orthodoxy an Orthodox
relation he would put them in the same
civilization as modern-day Greece and
the other now it's not that these things
are different but you have the irony
that people who if they are religious at
all and many are they use the same text
that other Christians do some of the
rituals are a bit different but they
pray to the same God and have the same
religious text so if that is the
determination then one wonders why you
split so the reason I make this point is
that
Toynbee makes a good bit of the argument
that Russia belonging in a different
civilization will never be or certainly
not in the foreseeable future be able to
have the sort of political system which
is more common in Western Europe and
North America
he places North America in in the
Western civilization now you know this
brings us to what do we mean by Europe
if you look at other historians and I
spent some time reading the historians
in the UH naal school
the French group and particularly
Rodell now bro Dell who wrote a masterly
history of the civilizations around the
Mediterranean now he would have divided
civilization quite differently from
Toynbee for him all the countries around
the meta duration radiant share a
civilization but he commented once
there's no such thing as European
civilization he said oh there's a
Spanish civilization there's a French
civilization there's an English
civilization there's a German
civilization and you can define and yes
they interact and so on but he said when
you make it as broad as Europe it
becomes meaningless because you can no
longer define it now he's thinking of
culture of course not just the politics
but it does seem to me that that is one
of the things we need to bear in mind
before we go too far in taking these
broad generalizations as somehow
operative in the present and applicable
to current political relations or for
that matter to the way a country may
evolve politically internally the other
side of that coin of course he'll go
back to the poem by Fiat or to Jeff the
Slava files they would have very much
agreed that Russian orthodoxy formed a
separate civilization and one that is
not subject to the sort of criteria that
you would apply in Western Europe faith
alone you can only believe in Russia
don't worry about trying to understand
it in fact the first line of this group
of poems was warm Rossi you in the
opinion by the mind one cannot
understand Russia
so and you this idea is very much
repeated in dusty upski implicit in some
of his novels very explicit in his diary
of a writer and it's very much connected
with the slava file tradition now one of
the interesting things for me at least
is that it was in the Western Iser
tradition not the sava file tradition
that Marxism came to Russia so in a
sense communism was based on a West
European ideology I mean how can you
describe it any other way
philosopher from tree air and the
Rhineland who writes his magnum opus in
England that is Western as you can get
so philosophically Marxism itself in
fact I've read some comments about
Europeans to say you know the problem
with the Russians is they take Western
ideas and they take them literally they
don't modify them like say we did when
we came up with say a democratic
socialism and the Russians take it so
literally that they foul it all up and
actually that maybe is something to that
but the fact is it's you can't really
say that Marxism and communism was not a
European idea and was not a Western idea
and these things do tend to get all
mixed up and I think when we generalize
too much or assume that simply because
Russia has generally had an autocratic
government it is doomed in the future to
have one we make a mistake I'm running
out of time I'm going to rush on a bit
to make some points because I did want
to say a few things about Russian
relations with the United States we
tended to think during the Cold
or about the confrontation we even
talked about a bipolar world as if the
two of us ran the world between us which
never was true but until the early 20th
century the best way to describe your
us-russian relations were distant
friends in fact that I think is one of
the titles that Norman saw who wrote
this multi-volume excellent history of
us-russian relations used you know even
in the earliest years of the Republic
when John Quincy Adams was our at that
time we didn't have ambassadors we had
ministers in legations he was our
minister to Russia and he and Alexander
Czar Alexander actually became well
perhaps friends is not quite the same he
would go out for walks along the
embankment when the Czar was out and
they would chat and for political
reasons Russia had a very supportive
relationship with the United States
despite the fact that it was a republic
and you know this continued through the
19th century Russia tended to side with
the Union during the Civil War when
Britain had real questions there and so
on of course in World War one and World
War two Russia and then the Soviet Union
was on the same side we were in fact
when you think about it Russia is really
the only major country in the world
except maybe France this is their
questionable time when we weren't
actually declaring war but we were
actually fighting the French that we
have not had a war with and that
probably tells you something about
national interests and whether they
conflict or not now the relationship was
one which broke totally and efficiently
after the Bolshevik Revolution not
because Russia was Russia but because it
went communist and because we feared the
influence of communists here the
Bolshevik Revolution there and the civil
war and Russia was followed by the Red
Scare in the United States with the
arrest of demonstrators and a real fear
that this socialist revolution was a
danger to us and of course until
Franklin Roosevelt was elected and then
established official relations with the
Soviet Union in 1933 for over a decade
we had no official relations the 30s
there was an attempt and unfortunately
the 30s coincided with Stalin's purges
collectivization the famines and so on
but in World War two
we ended up again allies and I would say
one thing is we look at this
relationship is that one of the things
that we need to bear in mind is that in
both countries there has been over time
a significant messianic streak I'll have
to put it that way a feeling that the
country had a civilization or values or
something which they were obligated to
spread and share with the rest of the
world even perhaps impose on the rest of
the world
we had a manifest destiny more recently
we have had our attempt to democratize
the Middle East and spread democracy to
countries that haven't had it in Moscow
the idea goes back even further just
after the fall of Constantinople to the
Turks you had Russian of
in rock writing about Moscow the third
Rome there was Rome there was continent
in opal and now Moscow as the standard
bearer of Christianity and no perhaps
this idea didn't extend very far outside
monastic or ecclesiastical circles but
by the 19th century it got tied up in
the whole idea of pan-slavism the idea
is that for example dusty of skate
understood very well and Dostoyevsky
would write passionately in his diary of
the writer of how it was the obligation
of the Russians are to protect the
Christians in the Balkans by liberating
Bulgaria by occupying Constantinople and
bringing it back to Christianity and it
was not to expand Russia but to protect
fellow Christians Widow I think there is
obviously are there differences in many
respects but then we have our one
Sounion ism we go to war to make the
world safe for democracy or more
recently to make the world democratic
and this took the form in the Soviet
Union that we call the Brezhnev Doctrine
if socialism is established somewhere
and they made the assumption that only a
socialist country socialism is they
defined it could be truly friendly and
non-threatening to the Soviet Union and
if a socialist government was threatened
it was their obligation to save that
government one of our presidential
candidates last fall talked about
setting up a league of democracies
apparently on the assumption if you have
enough democracies they're going to be
more reliable allies it does seem to me
that there is a mindset here that
is somewhat comparable and we need to
and it goes beyond expansionism because
I think in both cases these ideas have
been used for essentially imperialistic
purposes let's be frank but there's
another side to it and that is with
Russians maybe it's because of the Cold
War maybe it you know whole number of
reasons but the only other country that
really counts in terms of their policies
is the United States I was once asked by
George Shultz when we were after we were
negotiating some pretty tough issues and
we were riding out to the airport in
Moscow and he said tell the jack what do
you think these Russians really want and
I said they want to be more like us and
they want acceptance and almost
acceptance has to come first you find in
whether it's in the Slava files or the
others the feeling of inferiority and
once they begin to feel inferiority the
rest then that's when they go off on we
don't need your standards we have Sol we
are right we represent the true
Christianity or whatever when in their
hearts they want to be treated as we
treat the Europeans but a little better
than we treat the Europeans because they
see themselves as a great people and the
only other great country that they want
to emulate is the United States and and
that gives for the average Russian
relations with the United States at peak
when see and irrelevance that we don't
have toward Russia we come with
different attitudes and different
mindsets when we look at it many of our
citizens whose
ancestors forefathers and not too many
generations ago came from Russia came
out because of oppression they remember
the Cossacks and the pogroms and so on
and this is Russia and it was wasn't all
of Russia so we both have in a sense in
the case of Russians I would say sort of
a love-hate relationship in the sense it
well if you don't accept me then you
know you must be my enemy and you'll get
very great variation one way or the
other here in the United States it's a
little hard really politically to to
convince people that it's really
important for us to try to understand
where the Russians are coming from
because we need them also in a number of
ways it seems to me that as the Cold War
ended three geopolitically seismic
events occurred now Vladimir Putin has
been quoted as having said not too long
ago and more than once the greatest
geopolitical disaster of the 20th
century was the breakup of the Soviet
Union and people who quote that usually
don't quote another of his sayings which
he has said even more often and that is
you know anybody who does not regret the
collapse of the Soviet Union has no
heart anybody who would reconstitute it
has no brain the fact that he considers
the collapse of the Soviet Union a
geopolitical disaster it's probably
explainable by Russia's experience in
the 90s which I'll be talking about
tomorrow but in fact the Cold War ended
before
the Soviet Union collapsed I think three
things occurred that were so significant
geopolitically that they may be
comparable to the drift of continents in
geological time they certainly remade
the geopolitical map first was the end
of the Cold War which essentially ended
that east-west literal east-west
struggle
basically over ideology and in in my
opinion the ideological Cold War ended
in December 1988 when Gorbachev made a
speech at the United Nations in which he
not only said that they were going to
reduce their military unilaterally by
half a million but he also made the
significant statement that there is no
limitation on the freedom of choice that
a country has about its political system
now this is a renunciation of the
Brezhnev Doctrine a renunciation of the
right to intervene to keep socialism and
a renunciation of the foundation
principle of Soviet foreign policy up
till then which was based on the
assumption of an international class
struggle he dropped that and indeed the
next year when he put forward theses for
the Communist Party conference
principals there was not a hint of
Marxism in those theses it was almost
left as if they were cribbed partly from
the American Declaration of Independence
and partly from the American
Constitution and these you buy 89 know
those theses were already
eighty-eight by 89 they were being
fulfilled with contested elections and
so on so when the Cold War ended it
ended by negotiation we did not force
the Soviet Union to end the Cold War
gorbachev ended the Cold War because it
was in his interest to end it
he didn't made no concessions that were
not in his country's interests we didn't
ask him to do anything that was not in
his country's interest if the country
was willing to live in peace with other
countries this was one thing Ronald
Reagan understood and he would say when
we were developing our negotiating plans
you can't ask them to do something
that's against their interests but most
of the things they're doing are also
against their interests and we have to
persuade them of that their domination
of Eastern Europe was creating countries
that pated them the people did because
of the way they control them so the Cold
War ended not so much as a victory
certainly was not a military victory it
was ended by negotiation to the benefit
of both parties now having ended it made
it possible for Gorbachev to begin very
fundamental reforms in the Soviet Union
he could not have pursued those reforms
that the Cold War had continued because
the international tensions were such
that one of the first things he had to
do was to put more resources into the
civilian economy it was being robbed by
the military-industrial complex and and
yet as long as there was the tensions
and the Cold War how politically could
you begin to cut back on that you you
had to end that first and as once the
Cold War and the arms race was over he
felt free to try to reform the country
in a fundamental way and when he saw
that the communist
party Kendra's the professionals were
beginning to block these reforms he
decided he had to take the Communist
Party out of power it was not Western
pressure that brought down communism in
the Soviet Union
I was really outraged when Ronald Reagan
died and the cover of The Economist
magazine had the headline the man who
beat communism Reagan himself would
never have put it that way
in fact he puts in his memoirs that the
end of the Cold War was not a victory of
one country over another it was a
victory of one idea over any other and
it occurred when the other side
understood the ideas in other words was
reforming communism was brought down in
the Soviet Union by Mikhail Gorbachev
and he was the only man who could have
done it but he couldn't have done it if
the Cold War was still on having taken
the Communist Party out of total control
over the country then all the various
inequities pressures that had been
suppressed in the Soviet Union suddenly
came to the fore and Gorbachev one of
his principles was he made a lot of
political mistakes but he was simply
against try solving political problems
by force so he rejected all the ideas
that he should put down these things by
force and eventually it was these
pressures within the Soviet Union that
brought it down the United States tried
to prevent that from happening one of
the myths today and in particularly true
in Russia is that we brought down the
Soviet Union nonsense they did it to
themselves and they did it with our
President George Herbert
Bush the first President Bush doing his
best to support Gorbachev effort to
establish a voluntary Federation of all
the Republic's except the three Baltic
countries we always considered them as
having the right to independence and I
thought they should be liberated but we
did not want to see 12 independent
countries with nuclear weapons and for a
while there were nuclear weapons and
most of them and that wasn't the only
factor the fact was that by 1991 the
Soviet Union was a different entity than
the one it had been before and it was
changing even before that and you know
Ronald Reagan was well known for having
said in one of his speeches and I think
only one he referred to an evil empire
but then when he visited Moscow in May
of 88 and he was asked is this still the
evil empire he said well no that was
another time another era
things were changing he was recognizing
it and you know what those of us who
were living there and in contact I had a
staff that really we knew the opposition
and the communist leaders in all of the
Republic's and they stayed in contact
with us and it was very clear that the
Democratic opposition and most of the
countries outside the Baltic States were
being supported by Moscow and were alive
only because of that and of course when
the Soviet Union broke up when it did we
found in Central Asia every one of them
either were left in the hands of the
communist dictator that's the thing that
was there before except Tajikistan which
then had a civil war so in 91 we really
that is we American officials a
government from President on down did
all we could to support Gorbachev effort
to create a democratic and voluntary
Federation
bush made a memorable speech in Kiev
August 1st 1991 it was made to the
Ukrainian Parliament but we told the
press and our briefings that this is
directed at all the non Russian
nationalities the speech became a bit
infamous when bill Safire the column is
called it his chicken Kiev speech and
why was it a chicken Kiev speech because
he endorsed Gorbachev Union treaty and
he said two things that I think so far
either didn't understand or didn't refer
to he said do not confuse freedom and
independence there are not synonymous
choose freedom and number two he said
avoid suicidal nationalism what do you
have in mind
Georgia because gums succour dia was
conducting any effective war in South
Ossetia already and it was apparent to
that administration where that was going
to lead if it continued well I think one
can say in retrospect the Soviet Union
was unsalvageable
even if Gorbachev had put together Union
Treaty maybe it wouldn't have lasted
very long but the fact is that the idea
that somehow the United States using its
military force in its economic might
brought so much pressure to bear on
Gorbachev that he had to end the Cold
War brought so much pressure to bear
that it ended communism in the Soviet
Union and then broke up the Soviet Union
which was in our national interest gets
almost every one of those propositions
wrong and yet those ideas
have become part of the mythology which
you will see treated time and time again
and I've got to return to some of these
ideas in later lectures but I think I've
talked enough for this afternoon